Sometimes you’re at the airport and it’s
too thunderstormy, so you have to stay on
the ground.
I get that.
But sometimes it’s just hot, or cold, or
cloudy!
What’s going on planes?
Why can’t you fly?
Flight seems simple, though it is anything
but!
Planes are expected to traverse so many different
climates and conditions, and yet, they aren’t
magic, they’re based on science and engineering.
So, we try to break them.
Manufacturers flood the engines of their planes
to see how much water they can ingest flying
through a storm before failing.
They fire dead birds into engines to see how
many it takes to break the internal workings.
Test flights are done in varying levels of
ice, snow, and rainfall.
Engineers even figure out how long the runway
needs to be at different altitudes for planes
to stop safely.
But sometimes, nature gets in the way of best
laid plans.
For example, during a heatwave, planes can’t
even get off the ground.
Remember when temperatures soared to almost
120 degrees in Phoenix back in June 2017?
Planes were grounded all over the place.
When a plane is grounded for heat, it has
less to do with hot planes, and more to do
with hot air.
Airplanes fly when the air moving over the
wing is less dense than the air moving under
the wing, creating lift.
Hot air is less dense than cold air meaning
there are fewer molecules for the airplane’s
wing to fly on top of.
To get lift, the plane will need more speed
to get the air moving fast enough to generate
pressure on the underside of the wing.
In Arizona, the airport just didn’t have
a long enough runway to get planes going fast
enough when it’s hot!
So there’s no way to leave the ground.Cold
can also cause problems.
It’s very cold at 30,000 feet and above
-- so you’d think planes would be okay with
cold…
But not entirely.
The main issue is still about air moving around
the wing.
If ice builds up on a wing, it can change
how air moves -- screwing up lift, just like
with the hot air.
But also, jet fuel can, in fact, freeze if
it gets too cold.
There are jet fuel types, just like gas for
your car, and regular Jet A fuel freezes below
negative 40 C and the Jet A-1 fuel below negative
47 C!
You probably won’t get that cold even in
a Michigan winter, but in Russia or Antarctica?
It can be an issue.
Airplane manufacturers test their planes to
make sure pilots and engineers know what the
craft can and can’t do.
Just like some planes can fly higher or faster,
some don’t take off well in high winds,
or fly well with a strong tailwind.
Planes are even tested for turbulence tolerance!
Which ultimately comes down to how far the
wings can flex.
To test that, they put the wings through this
terrifyingly incredible test.
This is a stress test on a wing of a Boeing
777.
They built a machine to simulate the plane
carrying more and more weight, and it finally
snaps at 154 times what it was designed to
lift.
FYI: there is no way a wing would bend like
that or fall off in regular flight.
We have a video about it.
The goal of all these tests are to get the
plane to fail under more stress than the plane
will likely experience.
That way they know it won’t break under
normal flight and landing, and if something
does go wrong in extreme conditions, we understand
how and why it happened.
All this gives airlines the limits in which
the plane can fly to keep everyone safe.
And it works!
Commercial flying is still the safest way
to travel.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com
Have you ever wondered why some planes look
bigger on the inside?
We talked to some engineers about the tricks
they use to that, you can check it out here.
I love flying in big planes, the windows,
the design… it’s so cool to be in a giant
tube in the sky and not feel like it!
What do you think?
Tell us in the comments. Please subscribe for more Seeker, and thanks for watching.